Artificial intelligence and warfare.
Let's talk about
what this really could look like.
Swarms of lethal drones
with facial recognition
that know your every move.
Or unmanned armed robots
that are near impossible to defeat.
Autonomous fighter jets
that can travel at supersonic speeds
and can withstand
greater gravitational force
than a human pilot could survive.
Cyberattacks that incapacitate
critical port infrastructure
or disinformation campaigns and deepfakes
that throw presidential elections.
Or even foreign adversaries
taking out satellites,
our eyes and ears in space,
rendering us blind to global events.
All superintelligent weapons of terror.
We are at the dawn
of a new age of warfare.
I grew up in the birthplace
of a technology
that defined the last era of warfare,
the atomic bomb.
I was keenly aware of how this technology
had fundamentally shaped geopolitics
and the nature of war.
My parents were both scientists
at Los Alamos National Laboratory.
My dad’s a physicist,
and my mom’s an astrophysicist.
Their scientific work
in plasma fluid dynamics
will have deep implications
for how we understand our universe.
So naturally, I knew I wanted to work
on something just as impactful.
I decided to become a programmer
and study artificial intelligence.
AI is one of the most critical
technologies of our time
and with deep implications
for national security
and democracy globally.
As we saw in World War II
with the atomic bomb,
the country that is able
to most rapidly and effectively
integrate new technology
into warfighting wins.
There's no reason to believe
this will be any different with AI.
But in the AI arms race,
we're already behind.
From a technological perspective,
China is already ahead
of the United States
in computer vision AI.
And in large language models,
like ChatGPT,
they are fast followers.
In terms of military implementations,
they're outspending us:
adjusted for total military budget,
China's spending ten times more
than the United States.
Why are we so far behind?
The answer is twofold.
First, data supremacy.
Despite having the largest fleet
of military hardware in the world,
most of the data from this fleet
is thrown away or inaccessible,
hidden away on hard drives
that never see the light of day.
This is our Achilles heel.
In an AI war, everything
boils down to data.
For defense AI,
data from the internet is not enough.
Most of the data needs to come
from our military assets,
sensors and collaborations
with tech companies.
Military commanders need to know
how to use data as a military asset.
I've heard this first-hand many times,
from my conversations
with military personnel,
including most recently
from Lieutenant General
Richard R. Coffman,
deputy commanding general
for United States Army Futures Command.
Second, despite being home
to the leading technology companies
at the forefront
of artificial intelligence,
the US tech industry
has largely shied away
from taking on government contracts.
Somewhere along the line,
tech leaders decided that working
with the government was taboo.
As a technologist,
I'm often asked
how I'm bettering this world.
This is how I'm improving
the future of our world:
by helping my country succeed
and providing the best tools
and technology
to ensure that the United States
government can defend its citizens,
allies and partners.
(Applause)
The Ukraine war has demonstrated
that the nature of war has changed.
Through AI overmatch,
Ukraine is challenging an adversary
with far superior numbers
of troops and weapons.
Before the Ukraine war,
Russia had spent an estimated
65 billion US dollars
on its military expenditures,
whereas Ukraine only spent
about six billion dollars.
It's estimated that Russia
had over 900,000 military troops
and 1,300 aircraft,
whereas Ukraine only had
200,000 military troops and 130 aircraft.
Technologies such as drones,
AI-based targeting and image intelligence
and Javelin missiles
have enabled a shocking
defense of Ukraine.
AI is proving invaluable for defending
Ukrainian cities and infrastructure
against missile and drone bombardment.
At Scale, we’re using
our novel machine learning algorithm
for battle damage assessment
in key areas affected by the war.
We've rapidly analyzed
over 2,000 square kilometers
and have identified
over 370,000 structures,
including thousands
not previously identified
by other open source data sets.
We focused on Kyiv, Kharkiv and Dnipro
and provided our data directly
in a publicly accessible data set
to the broader AI community.
One of the key problems we're solving
is using AI to analyze massive amounts
of imagery and detect objects
because humans just can't keep up.
We've received an overwhelming response
from our free AI-ready data set
and have provided it directly
to the United States and NATO allies.
And it's been downloaded over 2,000 times
by AI companies, researchers,
developers and GIS practitioners.
AI can also be used for change detection.
Simply put, algorithms
can constantly monitor imagery
and notify a human to investigate further
if there's a change or a movement.
It's clear that AI
is increasingly powering warfare.
And based on the rate of progress
in the AI field,
I predict that in ten years,
it will be the dominant force.
Disinformation and misinformation
are already huge problems.
And this technology
is only going to make it worse.
Tools like ChatGPT
have enabled AI to generate imagery,
text, audio, video, code and even reason.
These tools can generate realistic-looking
and realistic-sounding content,
which on top of bot-run
social media accounts
will make it nearly impossible
to identify disinformation
and misinformation online.
Bad actors can use these tools
to supercharge misinformation
and propagate falsehoods.
China already uses
disinformation campaigns
and social media manipulations
heavily in Taiwan,
particularly during elections.
Or take Russia's propaganda machine,
which in the wake
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
created a deepfake
of Ukrainian President Zelensky
calling for Ukrainian troops to surrender.
This deepfake was easy to spot,
but the next one may not be.
This also takes place within our borders,
from social media algorithm manipulation
to advertising microtargeting
and geofencing,
to deepfakes of politicians
and bot-run social media accounts.
The United States is not excused
from exacerbating
disinformation and misinformation.
These tools are universally accessible
at low or no cost,
meaning they can be employed
by anyone anywhere
to undermine the sanctity
of democracy globally.
However, all hope is not lost.
If we properly invest
into data infrastructure
and data preparation,
all this can be avoided.
Deterrence is nothing new
to military thinking.
As we saw in World War II
with the atomic bomb,
it was a primary factor
in deterring foreign adversaries
from going to nuclear war
for more than six decades.
Because the stakes of going to war
with such a technology
were simply too high.
We're likely to see
a new calculus emerge with AI.
It's uncharted territory,
nobody knows what it will look like
or the toll it will take.
How do we know if our AI
is better than our adversaries'?
We won't.
But one thing is clear:
AI can only be as powerful
as the underlying data
that is used to fuel its algorithms.
Data will be a new kind of ammunition
in the era of AI warfare.
In the tech industry,
we often talk about missions.
They're often frivolous.
Do they really change
the world or save lives?
This mission, on the other hand,
really matters.
The AI war will define
the future of our world
and has the potential
to shift the balance of diplomatic power.
It's clear that digital warfare
is not some dystopian reality,
tucked away in a faraway future.
It is taking place in the here and now.
We cannot sit by the sidelines
and watch the rise
of an authoritarian regime.
It is in moments like this
that technologists can either rise
to the challenge or stand idle.
I encourage my fellow technologists
to understand the austerity
and severity of our times
and commit themselves
to supporting national security.
While I find it shocking
that most American AI companies
have chosen not to support
national security,
I do hope others join us.
We must fight for the world
we want to live in.
It's never mattered more.
Thank you.
(Applause)